[Música]
hoje o pessoal de quem falar andar diz
muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo finalmente um vídeo novo
sol e eu só nós vamos comer o conhecido
o famoso o fantástico segurou-se claro
ovo centenário o novo milionário chinês
subida em ouro preto o vodu saná jogo do
sul metade basicamente pessoal este é um
mundo muito mas muito horripilante 2º
pelotão ambiental dizem pela internet
mas elas pessoal deixa muito mais aqui
no espírito já sabes componente crítico
no canal inscrevam sou eu tinha uma
novidade para vocês que não tem nada a
ver com isso e méxico vocês vão adorar
aproximar e se aproxima e só sabem de 25
de abril vai cirurgia band ninguém só
então já não está em passar pelo cinema
ver um filme eu vou estar na estréia eu
quero muito ver este filme e vamos ver o
que é que mais ninguém o que pra mim ó
software que eu faça um vídeo
especificamente com machado o torque
comentei porque eu acho que esse
brinquedo é bem resistente a marvel em
vítimas eram todas do super heróis mãe
que usa um bico taraneh sabem dia 25 de
abril eu quero ver todos vocês no cinema
a vende hoje em um mundo vai ser
apanhado e sequer me anda a matar as
duas
nada disto estão já matou muita gente
botando isto com certeza eu não comento
para lá então só vamos comer o nosso o
centenário vamos começar a produzir só
eu sei que muita gente tem dúvidas em
relação e estou aqui dentro
este já tem um cheiro muito grave na
vida de muita gente por eles que este
povo tem mais de 120 anos que é um ovo
tem welles pensamos mas não só isso têm
em média entre 30 e echo a 100 dias onde
está a ser construído debaixo da terra
é um processo químico qualquer que vai
processar o felino é isso basicamente
nos enterramos completamente que chega à
terra pois ainda metem cinza ainda
mantém um salão e qualquer coisa
impossível e depois disso é só esperar
em um mês a 100 dias que eu vá ficar um
preto completamente preto por dentro do
ó e pensionistas que não é um pulinho
aqui o pato
meu deus eu ouvi nos auro que não sabe
disso
e outra coisa entretanto essa parte de
fora não for translúcida
uma ficaria muito puro e como vocês
podem ver
olha aí tava entrando você olha de fora
da china não só para quem acha que isto
é um estranho isso aqui é habitual a
escolherem no sul da china portanto
espanhol é uma iguaria para nós é só o
futuro do clube em nota
há muito que eu vou sentar com isto
cheira a mofo da ajuda chega mais cheiro
de mofo cheira muito mal é quando se
uniu à noite
o sub 11 11
eu vou morrer aqui com minha câmera
receberam informações que não precisava
só uma série mas tem que apoiar muitos
filhos achei muito laquê inscrevam se
forem inscritos foi encontrado somente
na estreia frente ao euro depois que o
vôo muito salgado é o pior
isso aqui é muito dela
[Música]
já a máxima parece lama em cima por
esses lama isso não seria prudente
conquistou uma cena do outro mundo eu
nunca vi isso na minha vida só me mexi
no meu
o chinês vocês têm como foco mesmo é pá
que é isto o que vocês fazem os pratos
music que tem muito o que jogar só tem
uma aparência pelo cheiro bem band lamb
por fora
só não me por dentro não estou sozinho
aqui um pacote suplementar equipamento
está gravata eu primeiro vou provar a
sua rotina após bater na trave
ó ó ó pá pá pá ea partir de então todo
só sabe quando vocês a roça mãe fazer
aquela comida que tem muita gordura da
carne
depois fica fria e depois tipo têm
quando seca e passou outro dia ea noite
têm aquela camada de gordura que a
equipe latina
cuidado com molho escola municipal
[Música]
não não não tem nada não quer ou não
quer água e isso nunca é hora ou não
dela não pode olhar pra mim eu olho para
isto porque eu não consigo no coletivo
não fosse por não conseguir ver isto
mesmo tempo a gente começou bom
agora o pessoal do rei
chego de mauá chegou a 1
[Música]
olha
é pior coisa que já vi na minha menina
nos obrigava a mesma estava morta
nunca tive o senhor assim é muito mal
muito mal
ah eu não consegui inglês que eu não
consegui completamente impossível mas
pessoalmente também é procurado assim né
vamos tentar comer agora da forma como
os chineses comem vamos abrir aqui outro
ovo e agora vamos tentar o inter sabe
melhor
está pior em que o chile se vestia short
harley cheira muito mal meu futebol
assim só tentei fazer com que um corte
onde o curso que se equilibrar tantas
latina forma clara como a gema por
dentro então tá aqui um equilíbrio
textura até bom agora vamos tentar
temporal
não que isto enche aplicado não estão
aqui temos aqui o nosso olho vou deixar
um pouquinho de falta mas só pra dar se
um saborzinho afastou por lá pessoal ovo
podre do centenário com conexão 3g não
vai
[Música]
o rio tem um boi
como é que alguém economista 5 ou sem
tempero 0 a 10 e 11 10 é o pior evento é
muito pó pô muito mal com o tempero e
méxico é muito horrível mesmo documento
agora 20 mil estão nem dá pra comer
esquece é muito poder
se você acha que conseguiu um investidor
compra em teste em mandar imprimir um
vídeo uma emulação integrado ao twitter
ou qualquer coisa assim eu quero ver
vocês o primeiro estupro só comentei em
baixo o que vocês querem que eu faça com
24 aos que querem que eu faça uma franca
alguém ou qualquer coisa assim como em
baixo o kaiowá o qual é muito triste
10 03 pureza é o pior e 10 não está aí
horrível seguro gento mas se vocês
souberem de algum restaurante que em
portugal há qualquer coisa que faça este
tipo duro mas bom mesmo em baixo também
de falta que eu quero muito a provar e
eu estava muito provavelmente a maneira
como os chineses fazem mesmo porque deve
ser bom eu acho a outra coisa se
quiserem que o como um novo 1 com o
feito do pacto lembro como tem também
que eu posso fazer
eis fiquei até a próxima